And council staff like to welcome Council Member
Amy Peck.
I can't even see that because the Claire so
at this time I'd like to welcome Director Kenneth Allen and Miss
Cheryl Johnson. Provide the Houston
Parks and Recreation Department budget. Good morning.
Good morning. Good morning. See, everybody is smiling and ready
to go right there. All right, well, good morning.
Thank you pro Tim and City Council for
just allowing us to present and your continuous support of
the Houston Parks and Recreation Department. Certainly over
the last three years, we've had to adjust and pivot and
make things work the best that we can.
Partnering with other directors, other partners,
has certainly been a challenge to deliver just regular parks and recreation
services. But when you think about us being as Lily
Paz, shelter sites, distribution sites,
just really doing things to accommodate the needs
of the public, I am so proud of the team that I have
the honor and pleasure of managing day to day.
And these are guys and women with boots on the ground that
are actually delittering our parks, actually mowing,
actually repairing roofs, plumbing,
and the staff that work with our children day to day.
I am so very proud of them because they go beyond and
above the call of duty. They work with the resources that
we have, sometime limited. But guess what?
They've made a way out of no way. And we do have some gaps,
but we are striving to continue to provide
services the best we can with what we have. So I want to honor them
and I want to thank them for their day to day effort. It takes a
huge coordination effort with my executive
team working hand in hand with their direct reports.
And I have them with me today. I like to introduce have many of them
with me today. I like to introduce them with me. I have my
security blanket, so if there's a question I can't answer,
I have Miss Cheryl Johnson, our Deputy Director of
Management and Finance, our CFO. I have. Abel Gonzalez,
deputy director of Green space management.
Michael Eisenman, Deputy Director of Facilities
Management and Development. Have. Deborah Lathan,
deputy director of recreation operations. Have.
Tom Angelos, deputy assistant director of Recreation
and Wellness. I have Jason Harsh, division manager of
our golf operations. Tom Bourgeois,
Division Manager of our Urban Park Rangers.
Estella Espinosa, Communications Manager,
and our Public Information Officer. Erica Madison, our Administrative
Coordinator. Mimi Rasmus, also our Administrative
Coordinator. Jerrell, Washington Council
Liaison. And also have Lucy Carrera partnerships
and legislative liaison. And also we have Lisa
Johnson, she's with GSD, but she's a Project manager for Parks
in terms of our capital projects. Next slide, please.
Within our department, in our general fund,
there are ten main areas that
has a combined total of $86.6 million.
In terms of us operating with this proposed
budget, that equates to about 195.1 FTEs.
Those major areas are green Space Management
with 22.6 million of the budget.
Community center operations,
11.9 million of the budget.
Recreation and wellness, 6.2 million.
Facilities management and development, 8.7 million.
Urban park rangers, 3.5 million.
Next slide, please. The Director's office
with 1 million. Our communications office with
771,000. We have our management and finance
team, 4.5 million. Utilities and
inventory, 15.2 million.
The Houston Zoo, 12 million.
Next slide, please. Our mission is
pretty holistic, and it's to enhance the quality of
urban life by providing safe, well maintained parks
and offering affordable programming for our community.
We provide fitness, sports opportunities,
nature, conservation, environmental education,
cultural awareness, arts and crafts, as well as leisure programs,
social and specialty classes for youth,
teen, adults and seniors. And then we
operate by a standard of care, which is a mandatory
requirement for our after school and summer enrichment programs.
And then we provide free mills throughout the city for use
summer and fall. Through a federal grant
administered by the Texas Department of Agriculture. We have
security, operations and dispatch services for
H park, for pools, for community centers,
for other facilities throughout our system.
Next slide, please. We manage park land
expansions, constructions, renovations,
inspections, maintenance of park facilities. We ensure
compliance with all part building codes, fire codes,
health codes, american with Disabilities Act. And then
when you guys think about it, our entire inventory,
we have maintenance, and we maintain over 39,000 acres of
land of parkland. This includes over 380
parks. And then we also take care of espionage, urban forest,
natural resources, sports fields, trails,
trees, and we also maintain the grounds for the library
as well as multi service centers. Next slide,
please. That's a huge inventory, and it takes teamwork
and working together and working with council and partners to
adequately serve the public. We're short in some areas
and we'll identify those, but I want to go to our revenues by
fund. If you look at our proposed budget revenues
by Fund for FY 23, we have our general
fund budget, we're proposing 793,000.
We have Fund 2100, which is our revenue fund.
Our proposed budget is 3 million, and that's
actually for events, birthday parties,
park facilities, team registrations, tree violation,
fines, lake Houston rentals, and the
rentals for tennis centers in terms of revenue. And then we have
Fund 21 four, our golf revenue fund,
we're anticipating or expecting 7.8 million in
revenue for Fund 21 five, our maintenance,
renewal and replacement, we're proposing 2.6
million. And then Fund 21 six, which is our bio
greenways, 2021.4 million.
Next slide, please. Terms of FY
23 revenue and some of the highlights.
This is our proposed FY 23 budget. Compared to
our FY 22 estimate. You look at our
general fund 1000,
we're saying 1000 less.
So I know that's not significant, but the fact that it's it's less
wanted that to be known. Look at Fund 2100 special
revenue, we're proposing to make 468,000
more. And this is budget revenue that's projected
because of pre pandemic trends.
Also contributions from the Astros Golf Foundation
for playground initiatives. So if you look at 21
four in terms of golf revenue, in terms of highlights,
we're proposing 565,000.
We're hosting the Houston Open once again, and we're projected to
increase some streams of revenue for golf as a result of
the tournament and some of the things that we're doing with the Open.
We look at Fund 21 Five, maintenance,
renewal, and replacement. We're projecting
300,000 contributions again, from the
Astros Golf Foundation. For neighborhood park
projects, we're looking at Fund 21 six,
bio greenways, we're projecting 270K
for that. Next slide, please.
Expenditures by fund. This is FY 20 three's
budget compared to FY 22.
Look at Fund and I'll go in more detail with this slide as we move,
as we progress through the presentation. But if you look at Fund
1000, our general fund, we're looking at over 8
million in expenses, right? You look at Fund
2100, special revenue, fund 274k
in expenses, fund 21 Four,
our golf revenue Fund, looking at 894,000,
fund 21 Five, maintenance, renewal and replacement,
343,000. And Fund 21 six,
our bio greenways 2020, we're looking at 22,000
in expenses. So next slide, please.
Fund 1000, FY 23 personnel
versus non personnel. Personnel is 54%
of the budget. That's at 46.6 million.
Non personnel is 46% of the budget at 40
million. Next slide, please.
Special revenue, 2100.
Personnel versus non personnel for FY 23 personnel
is 34% of the budget at 1.1 million,
and non personnel is 66% of the budget at
2.2 million. Next slide,
please. So, for our golf
special revenue, 21 Four,
personnel, 59% of the budget at 4.7
million, and non personnel, 41% of
the budget at 3.2 million.
Next slide, please. For our
maintenance, renewal and replacement, fund 21 Five,
personnel is 35% of the budget at 1.1
million. And then we have non personnel at 65% of the budget at
2.1 million. Next slide,
please. So,
Valo Greenways 2020, fund 21 six,
we have personnel at 83% of the budget at 1 million,
and we have non personnel at 17% of the budget at
212,000. Next slide,
please. So this slide actually
is it compares
FY 22s budget to FY 23 proposed budget,
and it describes the changes between the budgets.
Next slide, please. If you look at when we
focus on 22, as was an adopted budget,
the operating budget was 58 million.
And then the restricted budget,
we looked at 9.5. And with
a total budget for FY 22, which was
adopted at 67.2 million.
And then moving from FY 22 adopted budget to the FY 22
current change, we had the following adjustments made.
We had an restricted account and adjustments for 58
million. And then we had hope adjustments that went to 726,000.
And then healthcare
benefits. As far as active civilians, there was a
reduction actually of 103,000,
council surplus,
98,000. And then the zoo contract
in terms of annual payment, 10.5 million.
So after combining those adjustments, there was 11.3
million. And we got to our FY 22 current
budget of 78.6 million.
Next slide, please.
Moving from FY 22, our current budget
to FY 23, we made the following budget adjustments.
You look at health care benefits for civilians and long term disability,
310,000. FY 22 Hope Allowances,
we look at 251,023.
Hope allowance.
960,000. Minimum wage adjustments,
149,000. Municipal pension,
224. As far as a reduction,
so that was good news. You look at restricted accounts
at 221,000, and then the Zoo CIP
increase at 520,000.
All right, we have new facility allowance. This is the A leaf, bringing that
on at 588,000.
And then I love our park initiatives
that's been so beneficial to neighborhoods,
about 5 million. So we get to the FY
23 proposed budget of 86.6 million,
which is a 10.3% increase for the current
budget. Next slide, please.
We look at expenditures from 23. In terms of expenditure
highlights, we had some variances between
FY 23 and FY 22 budget.
All of the increases were due to Hope allowances,
minimum wage adjustments, and related benefits.
So explaining this by fund, you look at 1000,
our General fund. There's an $8 million difference.
This increase is in restricted accounts and
funding for the Mayor's Love Our Parks Initiative Fund,
2100. Special revenue is 274,000.
And this is a purchase
of sports fill vehicles to maintain our fields
and our inventory for Fields fund 21
four. As far as golf revenue, it's 894,000
for increased maintenance costs and upgrades to
the course. To ensure that we meet
the PGA standard to deliver the tournament
here in Houston, we have our maintenance renewal and replacement of 343,000.
This is due to an increase in maintenance and park maintenance and repair
cost. You look at fund 21 six,
greenway, greenways, 2020 of 34,000.
This is mainly the purchase of new vehicles and equipment.
This actually concludes our budget presentation. I went
through it pretty quick. You guys may have questions. We also have
some department demographics and accomplishments in the
appendix in the back. I like to open this
up for questions. I want to thank my team for certainly joining me.
That's behind me. Thank you.
Thank you. We have a couple of council members in queue. We'll start off with
council member Abby Cayman.
Thank you so much, Director. And the entire team.
Really quickly, on page 16, the health benefit adjustment,
the 103. Can you just explain a
little bit more on that?
Health benefits for active civilians in terms of the reduction
of 203 I'm sorry,
$103,000.
Could you elaborate on that for me, please? Yeah, it's mostly due to
when we look at the health benefits for the active civilians,
when people retire, your employees retire and we bring on new employees,
we budget them at the lowest health
benefit rate in hopes that they're going to come in.
And so we budget for just lower than
if somebody retire after being there 32, 35 years somewhere.
Okay, understood. I wasn't sure if that was a COVID correlation or
what. It just stood out to me. Thank you.
While we never wanted a pandemic,
still wish we weren't dealing with some of it. But one of the things that
came out of it was the greater appreciation I think we have for being outside
and the services that you all provide day in and day out for
our park system and not just the enjoyment of the outdoors, but Director,
to your point, the support we provide for our youth through the Parks
program I know you talked about the Meals program. Every year I
bring up one of my favorite programs we do at the city is the after
school programs, not only giving kids
a safe place to be while their parents may
still be at work, but the folks that work in your
department are providing tutoring crafts.
I remember one night I was at a civic club meeting at Cherryhurst,
and it had to be 1030 at night, and there was still
an employee there teaching one
of the kids how to play chess so that he could be on the school
team. And that dedication just
changes lives. So thank you for that really quickly.
Given the financial constraints that we continue to face at
the city, what are some of the needs that currently are not being
met, and is there anything you want to flag for council that may be coming
up in the future that we need to be aware of as a need that
is not sustainable right now. Based on this budget in
terms of facility renovations and
park maintenance and reducing our
moore's cycles, we're currently on
basically a 21 day cycle for
much of the park land throughout the city. We do have some partnerships,
and we're engaged with some community groups that help us take care of
parks, but that's one of the major things. We want our parks in great
condition, but currently, because of staffing levels
and budget, we would love to reduce our mooring cycles.
That's number one.
And then two, in terms of delivering services,
we're limited to the amount of staff that we have at each location.
And so sometimes we're relocated to partnerships and opening
and closing doors, with our primary programming
being our after school program and then some specialty classes where we invite
other groups to come in. So we have to do a lot of that,
but mainly our Mourn cycles and then
support for our youth in terms of programming,
oh, I can't forget, and he'll kill me if I walk out of here
without saying it. Our facilities in terms
of upkeep and maintenance, we have some
aging facilities. We need a lot, but we take care
of them as best we can. Thank you.
Like to welcome council member Sally Alcorn and Council member Carolyn
Evan Chabaz to the horseshoe. Council Member Amy Pick.
Thank you, Mayor Pro TEM. And thank you, Director for the presentation director.
Has there ever been a study to see if
for the Mowing of the Esplanades and the libraries and multi service centers,
if working with Public Works to leverage funds
or contracts, that kind of thing, would save any money?
We certainly encourage collaborations
and working together with other city departments,
the Esplanades are very
intense. We get to them like
a third priority after we mow the parks
and after we take care of other business. But that's
a critical area because we want them to look as nice as everything else.
As far as collaborating with Public Works,
I think they're just as limited as we are. We do
collaborate with neighborhood groups that want to maintain. That's been our
best way to kind of dig into the inventory
of espionage, but without partnering and us
being a solo on it. 22 to 24
days is what we are now based on resources. So we
welcome collaboration with any department or neighborhood
group to help us eat into that. Thank you.
Council Member Sally Alcorn. Thank you.
Along those same lines, on the performance measures in the budget
book, you have actually a target of 27 days on the mowing
cycle. And just back a couple of years ago, it was 21.
And those six days make a heck of a lot of difference. So I'm
also interested in, and I'm trying to find in
the raw data, where can I find the
mowing dollars? I mean, you have a landscape and
gardening. Do you remember the name of how you
classify mowing? It's not listed as mowing.
Okay, you can get that to me later. We can get that
specific. And on the health benefits question that Council member Cayman asked,
I mean, I see consistently across all departments a
big savings in health benefits. It's consistently
over the years. And this is a 400 million plus expense
we do every year.
I know we want to have enough money for health benefits always, but we're overdoing
it by quite a bit, and then those savings are passed back to
the department. So that $103,000 is just because we're
overstating what we think we're going to need on health benefits. And I've seen that
kind of across the board on that. Okay?
That's all I have. If you could just get the exact mowing costs,
I'd like to see that. And are they broken out by parks and
libraries and Esplanades, or is it just
kind of one? It's actually
in one. So green space management. So if you look at
the green space management budget, that's where you have it.
So we don't have really anything broken down. Now, some of them have
individual call centers, but not all parks have. Okay, so just
in the green space management. And one thing I know we've talked to the city's
naturalist about, and thanks to Barbara Quattro,
in a leaf, she has brought up the linear forests,
putting more trees in the Esplanades so the grass isn't growing so high.
Also using more, we've had a big meeting with the natural
plantings in the esplanades, which don't require as
much mowing. So what is the department doing to further
those initiatives? One thing, in terms of partnerships
with neighborhoods and community groups, we have several
of our Espanas that are maintained by neighborhoods.
So that definitely help. They have to do it
by park standard, of course, in terms of what you're planning and how you're
maintaining. But that's been great over the years,
and we hope to enhance that effort. Thank you,
Council Member Robert Gallegos. Thank you,
Chair. Talking about the esplanades as well.
First of all, I think you all do a pretty good job with the number
of esplanades you have in the city of Houston to try to keep all them
maintained. But there are two or three esplanades
over there by Gulf Gate. I know that the Pecan Park Civic Club
has complained, and I believe it's because
the esplanades are all concrete, but the cracks have
grass that's growing that's like 2ft tall.
So the civic club,
PECOM Park has complained about that. So I'm hoping that
can be addressed where they can go out. And again, I know they don't
go out there regularly due to the fact that they're concreted over.
It's not dirty and grass or what have you, but in between
the cracks, the grass does grow and the grass kid you not.
It's like 2ft tall. So if that can be addressed,
it'd be great. Also, in regards to the golf special
revenue fund or the golf expenses,
I know that the Houston Golf Association
took over Gus Worthham golf Course. It's still a city golf course,
and this course was done back under the previous administration.
And what I thought it was like a trial basis to see if
they would be successful, and I think they've proven that they are successful.
Is there still discussion of maybe the Houston Golf Association
of taking over other city golf courses, even though it
will be city land, city property, but they would
just maintain it and manage it and what have you?
No current discussion as far as golf association taking
over golf courses with our involvement with
the Astros Golf Foundation and the Astros
primarily at Memorial Golf is doing great right now in terms of revenue.
A lot of people are planning. We're able to maintain the courses appropriately,
and then we do have Herman that's coming up pretty
soon in terms of consideration of operating in
November. So that may
be on the table soon. Okay, you put me back in. We'll put
you back. Include in queue council member Tasha Jackson.
Thank you. And thank you, Director Allen, for your presentation and
just all your work that you've been doing and working with my office on
trying to get our parks. Just understand where
we're going with the parks and the need. And I know we've done a lot
of tours over the past two months, the parks in my district.
And just talking to your staff, one of the things is we needed more staff.
You need more staff to cover some of the maintenance that's
needed within the parks. And so I'm just curious. I see that there's an
increase of 10.3%. We have the
love our parks initiative. So is the extra staff and the 5 million
that's in the Love Our Parks, or have you included additional staff?
I know our conversation was I know we need money, so we need to ask
for what we need. I just want to make sure that we're
aligned. And so is the additional staff in this budget.
No additional staff, but just resources
and material to get that type of work done and then
outsourcing as we need to, especially with the Love Our
Parks initiative. As we complete those projects.
We have five more parks we're going to this fiscal year.
We did five last year. But contracting
out has been a way to complete some of the projects
and then just the raw material that's needed for the
upgrades, purchasing that. So one of the
ways I operate is I do, like, a pento budget and
like a Bentley budget. Like, what is your Bentley budget? Because I'm sure this is
a pento budget. What is it that you actually need? I know my colleague
asks those questions. What do you need to actually give the community
what they need? And that's parks that's functionable that they can use.
And so, of course, we've seen the parks in my district, and I know my
other colleagues have visited the parks. And so what is it that you actually need
to do your job? That's a load of questions for me.
With Houston being the fourth largest city in a nation,
we cover a lot of territory for
us to get to 14 days or seven day mourning
cycle. It's going to take a tremendous amount of money for
us to get there. And then facility upgrades. When you think about
we have agent facilities, agent pools, it's immense.
I'll have to do a study or some type of
document that would assess all of our
facilities and then our programs, as well as things that
we need to upgrade. But I'll need a little time to
get that together for you. I don't want to just throw out a number,
and it's not nearly what
I need to tell you, but it's extensive. I will say that. Okay. And I'm
still waiting on my list from the parks that we tour so I can get
that dollar amount based upon what the community said that they
would like to see in the park. And that way we can know what we
need, and then we can advocate for those resources. And thank you. You're welcome.
Council Member David Robinson. Thank you, chair and director.
Thanks for everything you do with the limited budget I think some of
the comments we're hearing from around the horseshoe just really underline how
you do so much with so little. And while we're talking about
things related to the request my council colleague just made,
time and money and personnel would solve a lot of problems.
So recognizing all that, I think you're coming
here with your presentation on the heels of the discussion with the General
Services Department. And some of what we spoke about already today
was deferred maintenance. And as an observation,
when one doesn't mow the esplanade,
that deferred maintenance becomes very obvious.
Witness my colleague, council Member Gallegos, with the problems down
by Gulf Gate and hear the things that we're saying around
town. So you hear from us all the time. In recognizing
that, I want to appreciate what you're doing with limited
dollars and all those special revenue funds and special
projects that are piled one on top of the other.
With our fast and wonderfully positive changing City
Mayor Turner's Parks initiative,
what we've done recently with celebrating the Zoo, some of
our Bayou Greenways initiatives, of course, and with
the golf program, to name a few. I want to focus on
some of what we've described already today as master
planning initiatives, whether that's the parks master plan,
whether that's a master plan for tennis, which I appreciate.
You've got a section in the appendix about other accomplishments where
you talk about as you know, what we've been working on with the tennis program,
and I just wondered if you can give a little narrative
overtone of how you see things
in that master planning category of
our parks facilities. Because those, famously, as the Adage
goes, a master plan tends to get on a shelf and collect dust.
But what can we do to help you push forward?
Specifically, in my case, curious about tennis, but what can
we do as a council to support your good work?
That's a great question, because when you think about the history of our
park system, we've been through several different master
plans and initiatives moving forward.
I think collectively, if we look at all the directors in
the other departments, one in Planning, of course, one with GSD
Public Works, we're currently working together for the Love Our
Parks initiative in several different areas.
So from a citywide perspective, we look internally
what we can do together for improvements. And then from
a more broad perspective, we look at
our partners, partners like Houston Parks Board,
partners like the Buffalo Bayo Partnership, all of
our partners, and then we look I think we have to look extensively
past and beyond what we could do internally. And then
from a study standpoint, we do our needs assessment,
evaluate that, and then we just come together and figure out
where the gaps are, and we redevelop the Parks master plan.
I think our last plan was 2016,
and we're currently trying to get to the point
where we update that by 2024
for our accreditation through NRPA.
We need a solid master plan to
present to receive our accreditation. So we'll be working on
that aggressively in the next year. And the tennis program will
be part of that, sir? Absolutely. Tennis has taken
a unique, I would say, position right
now because we invited prose consultant
a few years ago to come in and do kind of a study on where
we are and where we need to go. We have a draft document that we're
tweaking now that we'll unleash with the help of zena
Garrison who we hired as our tennis manager.
There it is. Can you say that again out loud? There's the first time I've
heard that. Zena Garrison we hired as our outreach
and our manager for tennis. So she's
coordinating with our new deputy assistant director,
tom Angelos, who is in the room. We're going to work together
on that plan and finalize it,
which will also encompensate our master plan that we have to
produce and submit
to receive our accreditation by 24, I believe.
Is that the right date? Yeah. Amazing. Well, you said Zena Garrison.
I'm excited about that. Thank you for mentioning it. The other two words to say
I think I just heard council member alcorn say it. Pickleball.
Yeah.
I'm going to challenge you all to try pickleball.
We're planning on using the sport of pickleball.
It's similar to tennis, and we're going to actually
provide an opportunity for the public to play. We hope
to establish about 30 courts throughout Houston combined
with tennis. It's a unique sport.
It's fast paced. There are several different division.
Tom Angelos are newly hired. Well, he's been on for
almost a year now. He's a pickleball advocate.
And we're promoting not only developing courts with
tennis, but also programming along the way.
We're hosting the national pickleball tournament in
October at memorial park. So when we get closer
to that date, I would love for you guys to come out and take a
look at it. Absolutely. Thanks again, director, you vice
mayor pro TEM Martha castex Tatum. Thank you,
chair director Allen, thank you so much for your presentation.
I heard you say that esplanades were the third priority
after the parks and some other services and then our esplanades.
I was driving home on yesterday along Kirby.
I usually go on 59, but I went down Kirby because the freeway is closed
at 610 and I saw a group of contractors putting
down turf in the esplanade, and I thought
that was a genius idea. So my question is,
what's your thoughts on turf in the esplanades?
And I noticed that along that Kirby street
headed towards holcomb, there are lots of trees, so the grass
doesn't grow there. So I know they were putting that artificial
turf down because they can't get the grass to grow there. But it looked
amazing. I said I was going to go back down that way today to
see what the. Finished product looked like, but there was a whole crew there,
and they were putting down turf in the esplanade. I'm interested
to know your thoughts on that, because if that's a thing,
I'd be interested in having some artificial turf
and some espionage in District A.
That's a pretty amazing idea. We have some wonderful partnerships with
neighborhoods in terms of taking care of their
espinates. It's called the adopt Espinate
program. And so there's some great ideas. Turf is very
expensive to put down up front, but you don't have to maintain
it. So I like to explore that idea even more.
I'll go by there today and take a picture of the finished product and send
it to you, and we can explore that a little more. I'll appreciate it.
All right. Council Member Carolyn Evans Shabaz.
Thank you, Mayor Pro. Tim. Thank you so much. Director Allen.
We've had a lot of engagement about our park
rich, District D. I wanted to ask,
how often are the esplanades cut?
I just got a call, and they're saying that they think they need
to be cut every two weeks. I don't know what kind of cycle they are
on, and maybe it depends on where they're located.
We're actually on a 28 day cycle for espionage, but I
think every two weeks is a little much to be
able to maintain for a full city. So I was just curious.
So it's a 28 day cycle, at least 28 days. But many of
our espionage are adopted by civic clubs and neighborhood
groups, and so that's been great. In some areas.
It's kind of like having a garden and having volunteers kind
of maintain it. We do have standards, and there's a process for
adopting an espinate. I encourage communities to get
involved with that. It's certainly a way to keep neighborhoods
beautified. In terms of volunteerism,
my last question, how do the sectors factor in to
money? Because I know that we have a lot of parks, but we
don't get as much money in regards to the sectors.
The park sectors are specific to the development
that's happening in those sectors, and monies are allotted to
that specific sector. I've had recent conversations
with legal about how we can possibly
even the playing field in terms of
money and development throughout this city. We are looking at
some potential options that we could get into in
terms of sharing in the future. But I don't have a document for you guys
just yet, but we're looking into that. Okay, thank you very much.
Thank you. Council Member Mary NAN Huffman.
Thank you, Director, for everything that you do. How many escalades are adopted,
do you know?
Mr. Gonzalez?
About 1000 acres. Okay. And you've talked about the program,
the Adopt an Esplanade program,
but I don't see a lot of advertising for it. What do we do to
encourage civic associations and homeowners associations to engage
in that program? Oh, definitely, if you guys have newsletters,
put them in your newsletters online,
and we can develop a campaign to actually assist
with that from our communications office. But I think it's
a great idea to get more exposure toward that program.
And then also, if one esplanade is adopted,
what does that equal in savings for the city?
Or is it by acre? Oh,
our expense per acre is about mr.
Gonzalez 2828
$2800 per acre.
Thank you. Council Member Robert
Gallegos. Thank you, Mayor, for Tim.
Director, in regards to I know there's a y'all are in
need of lifeguards. I am so glad you brought
that up. Are we we
have 37 pools throughout this city, and I would love
to open all of them. You guys know last year we only opened ten.
This year, we're scheduled to do just about
that. Again, there's just a shortage. We don't have
the same amount
of young men and women coming out to lifeguard.
They're choosing other things. Our workforce used to be about
50% return, but after we closed pools,
we lost that workforce, and we're aggressively trying to
regain it. But for a young
adult starting at 16,
we have opportunities anywhere from a pool supervisor to
a head lifeguard and a lifeguard. And we take this profession
very seriously because you're responsible for lives in that
pool. We want to operate safely, and we want to make
sure we have everything we need at each location. So if
we were to open a day, it would be about ten or
eleven pools. We're aggressively recruiting and asking
for help so that we can open more.
And we'll do that from a strategic standpoint. In terms
of attendance in the past, we may go to a rotating
schedule. Two pools open on this side of town
or in this district, and then maybe Tuesday,
Thursday, and then two on another side, maybe Wednesday,
Friday. But we have to get creative in providing these services
across the city with what we have in terms of staffing resources.
But we're aggressively recruiting right now, and I'm hoping you reach
out to the District council members so that way we can have input as to
what pools we think should be opened. I know Clinton Park
has already reached out to me, and there's no other pool in the area,
so I think Clinton Park would be a great pool to open in
District I. And my last question here,
looking at the demographic breakdown again,
with nearly half the population being Hispanic, only 29% are
employed by the Parks Department are Hispanic.
So I'm hoping that there can be some improvement on that.
And if you could also please provide me with a breakdown of the
demographic breakdown for the management of
the Parks Department, I would appreciate it. Thank you.
Certainly. Council member Abby Cayman. Thank you,
Mayor. Pro TEM. Really quickly, director, one thing that's been
on my mind here in Houston we talk a lot about flooding, as we should,
but we also have cyclical droughts.
87% of the state right now, and I think over half of Houston
itself is actually in a drought. Are those
costs calculated in, or how much more
cost is it when we're dealing with a drought? So having to water more?
Again, 2011 cost millions of dollars
in Memorial Park alone from the loss of trees. So if
you could just speak to that really quickly in terms of that cost calculation.
As far as the cost breakdown, I don't have any history
from previous droughts. I just know we had to recover.
We had to do specific things in terms of soil,
in terms of plants, in terms of placement,
but I don't have any data that could
support it at this point. I could certainly do a
little bit of research with our green space team and get you
something specific, no problem. And then lastly,
council member Robinson, I think me and director Allen could
definitely take you and council member Alcorn on in a
doubles with pickleball. So let us know whenever you want.
We'll be there. What time is session over with?
Thank you. Anytime you guys would like to, just let me know.
We have five public speakers. Before that, I'd like to go to
slide eight that's on the list. And it's about Memorial Park Golf
Course. I had the opportunity to play Saturday. I went there for
the beginning of the first tea event they had over there. And I just
wanted to highlight we get 1.1 million $333,000
as a gift from the Astros Foundation. I love the fact
that you all aerated and put some sand all over the course. And we
really need to have that course, as you know, in great shape in November
for the tournament, because if you remember last year,
it wasn't in good shape. And there was a quote in a Sunday paper
that when we all picked it up and reread it, we were embarrassed by it,
and that was the winner of the tournament. Jason Cocrot was quoted as
saying, I would have shot seven shots better if I
wasn't hitting off of mud all day. So as Memorial Park
golf Course, so goes the rest of the golf courses in the city because we
use the proceeds and we fund a lot of our operations with that. So I
see a lot of good work out there. So thank you for that. Director.
One thing that I did talk to Ms. Julie Blum about is
summer jobs program. Texas A and M has a great golf turf
management school. Have we reached out to them, or does
it make sense that we do reach out to them and try and get
some of those young kids that are studying turf
grass science and come to Memorial and spend a summer?
It look good on their resume that they worked on a PGA tournament
golf course. And I think we have hard time attracting
employees out there right now because we just don't,
quite frankly, pay enough. And they get other opportunities at
other golf courses all around the city. So we're disadvantaged
right there. But using some of those Texas A and M kids, I think
would make a good sense to get that course ready, because the
growing season is upon us, and if we don't have
it ready in November, the Houston Open
will not be at Memorial Park. Again, my opinion
and many other people's opinions. So we're doing a great job of trying to get
it there, but I want to raise that warning flag and say we
have to nail it in November. If we do nail
it, we get an opportunity, a golden opportunity, to move
it to April. And what happens in April,
we don't compete against football. We don't compete against basketball,
and we don't compete against baseball. And our attendance numbers
will zoom, and the higher they go, the more money we will
receive from the Astros Golf Foundation. So any
comments on that? Last year was
unfortunate in terms of some of the results of maintenance
of the course, I believe we made those adjustments to
move forward. We're currently looking for a senior
superintendent that we're working with, the Astros Golf
Foundation as well as a PGA. I think
we have qualified and great staff there. Now in
terms of maintenance of the course, we won't have the issues that
we had last year with the Greens and their approach shots.
Major focus. If you see the Agronomy plan that
we're working on now, you can already see improvements.
So I'm confident that we will meet the standard that we need to
meet this year because we're making adjustments
accordingly, and I know you will. So thank you for that. Council Member Carolyn
Evan Shabaz. Thank you, Mayor. For.
Tim and I did want to take this time to tell you thank you as
well. We had our first Te graduation on this
past Saturday. It was great. We had 16 students
that participated in a program for a few weeks,
and you were the impetus for that idea, you and
Steven, my constituents director. The young people
really enjoyed it, and more importantly, they have opportunities
to maintain the game and perhaps get scholarships.
And so that's so very important. So I wanted to make sure that I did
thank you for that. Thank you. We have
five public speakers. Same rules apply for this session as last. First we'll
have Miss Saba blinding Director.
Thank you for your comments, and I appreciate it. Thank you very much.
Hello. Good morning. First. Before I forget, I wanted to
follow on Council member Alcorn and Council member Cayman's comments
about drought. And I love the idea of putting some more native grasses
and native plants in our esplanades, in our cross just to
help. And also,
I wanted to speak on behalf of my ten year old, who could not be
here this morning due to testing. She would love to
see more skate parks in the city of Houston. She is a great
fan of the Lee and Joe Jamel skate park as well as the
lessons you offer through them. And she also shared a desire for more gardens
like the McGovern Centennial Gardens. She also asked about sidebalks
and I told her that was a whole nother bag.
And just as a mom, I cannot say enough
good things about the Parks Department. I frequently have conversations with other parents
discussing both of our love for Houston parks programming and
a desire for more as they quickly fill up once open to the public.
Just a quick anecdote. A friend of mine once shared the long list of incredible
Houston camps his sons attended and that of
all of them, the Cherryhurst camp through the Parks Department was their favorite.
And they liked it so much that the next summer it was the only program
they signed up for. And I could say more and more about
what parents talk about. Thank you, Ms. Blanding. Thank you. We're running
behind already. Could I just a quick question.
5 seconds. Okay, thinking citywide. What would it look like to
expand and grow current programming equitably across the
city? So thank you for the question and we
are directing director Allen and Ms. Johnson that we
will field all the questions. So we will go ahead and take that.
If anybody has any answers to Ms.
Blanding's question on council, please feel
free to chime in. But as a good teacher would
say, you're dismissed. I just want to know what it
would be look like. I mean, I can't say enough good things about the programming
and so what would it look like to expand it more equitably
across the city of Houston? Getting tongue tied today.
I mean, funds are limited. I'll give you an example. We have no city run
parks in Kingwood, and we have one city run park in Clear Lake.
So I have one. And we
have Lake Houston Wilderness Park, which is the most underappreciated
park in the city, maybe in the south,
but I think that a lot of it comes
from you all. South in the US.
I think a lot of it comes from you all based on the dynamics and
the circumstances of each district, understanding what
the needs are of each neighborhood and what you would like to see from a
programming standpoint as well as a recreational standpoint.
And so we lean on you all to let us know as your
council members on what you would like to see within your own footprint.
And then we will work within ourselves, either through our council district service
funds or directly with the Parks Department on trying to find ways
to improve parks with those specialty needs. Yes, and if you
have any ideas, please send them to us. We will make sure that we pass
them along and then we will give them to your appropriate council member as well.
Because as we keep talking about, we do have council district service
funds that we can use for some of our parks
activities. I know we use some at our Sylvan Rodriguez
Park down south. I appreciate the invitation. Yes,
ma'am. Mr.
Council Member Robert Gallegos. I'm sorry.
First of all, thank you for being here. Appreciate you being here.
I know that Mayor Turner has the
50 50 parks. He's reaching out to corporations to
hopefully put some monies in parks that have been neglected
in many of our districts. I know that at Hartman
Park there in Manchester, we were able to get valero. That was the
first 50 50 park. They were able to put monies for
new play equipment because I kid you not, some of their play, the play equipment
was rusting. And a
lot of people are surprised on the cost of play equipment.
It was about $660,000 for
new play equipment at at Hartman Park. So that that's what we're
running into is that the cost is just so expensive.
And I've got a request at Fondi Park last week at my
redistricting that they're just looking for new swings.
I asked them, do you need the whole play equipment? They said, no, we just
need new swings. So I'm going to put in the cost to the
parks department to see just how much do swings cost. And I'm
afraid to hear the price tag just for swings, but I'm
going to try to do that at Fondue Park as well.
Thank you, Mr. Landing. Thank you, Mr. Jason Oliver.
Thank you.
So I just got here late during the last presentation, but I wanted to
ask, why is council fielding our questions
instead of the because every committee I let it get away.
That was my fault. I let it get away from us yesterday. That's why we
ran overtime. We're going to limit people to 1 minute like we gave instructions
on. And in every committee meeting we have in the city of Houston,
questions come to council members, not to department directors.
So we're going to keep with that as elected officials.
That's on us. It's our budget process as well.
So we're going to go back to what I should have done yesterday and
that was my fault. So we
won't be able to likely get the answers to our questions
or at least clear answers in time for the well, hopefully you all
can get answers back quickly. Yes. I mean, our path is within 48 hours,
we get the questions posted, we get the answers. And I
would invite you to talk to your respective council member and
make sure you get those answers to those questions directed back to
you. Okay. In the past, the parks
department has said that they can easily double you soccer participation
with just a few more staff to administer the program. Your general
fund spend is about 200,000. Basically the same as five years ago.
Is there an opportunity to still reach an additional 50,000 students
through that programming? And I also want to know how competitive lifeguard pay is.
So I'll take our lifeguard pay. That's why
we're having trouble right now. Is it's not competitive,
especially with some of the different swim clubs that we have around
that pay a little bit more than we do. So you
answer your question. It's not competitive enough to answer
your question. I think it was about soccer. Yeah, a lot of the soccer
fields in the city of what's that? $11 an hour?
A lot of the soccer fields I'm a soccer dad. All three of my kids,
13 to 16, is the official answer.
Director Allen competitive? Correct me if I'm wrong. Your question
is about soccer fields. A lot of our soccer fields are leased to a lot
of these soccer organizations, and we monitor the activity
on them. So if they're leased, they actually control the soccer fields
like the Houston Golf Association controls
Gus Worthham Park. So it's up to those folks to decide.
Oh, no, my question was because the soccer program
is grant funded, and in the past they've said that
they could double the participation with more General Fund dollars
for administration. The the limitation is, is General Fund
spend on administration, not for. So that could easily
ramp up. I'm trying to figure out if that's still the case, if we
still are kind of leaving students out when we could allocate another
quick 200,000 to really ramp up our soccer
participation for children in Houston. Right. And thank you.
We will post that question and get that question answered.
Lauren Johnson.
Hi. So the after school enrichment
program currently operates at 51 community centers locations
throughout the Houston area, and they service about 2500
youth with a ratio of 1.25.
So where is that in terms of adequate or optimal
staffing? And how could we strategically fund that
expansion in the short term?
Anyone want to take this one on?
Okay, we will get that answer posted. And I would invite you
to get in touch with your council member for the answer to
that question. Once again, public speakers
should submit their questions in writing, and then we will
get in writing a written response back to you within 48 hours to
your particular district council member or at large.
Joe Grochell so
my question is, the Parks Department seems to be on par with the
libraries in its significant community reach and impact.
And how many Houstonians do you think you are able to
serve with every dollar?
Apparently not enough parks are I
told you about my experience. We have no Houston parks in the area that
I live in. We have one Houston park in the area that is Clear
Lake, and there's a great deal of demand.
Fortunately, we have good county parks in both of those areas that we
partner with in many, many ways county has done a fantastic
job. My opinion of building parks in
and around the city of Houston, in the ETJ areas,
the city of Houston, we struggle a little bit because of the
lack of funds that we have available, but we do the best job that
we can given the fact that the funds are not as
plentiful as they should be. And if anyone wants to make
a foundation donation, I would contact the great number of foundations we
have in and around the city that are very philanthropic with
their efforts, and contact them and adopt a neighborhood program to
adopt a neighborhood park. We've done that in the area that I live
in. We're responsible for the mowing of the grass,
the new soccer equipment, and we even had a fundraiser for the
lights that we put up. Now, not every community has
the ability to do that. I get it.
But I think philanthropic areas of
funding, we have a great number of folks in and around
this Houston area. I'll throw out the Brown
Foundation. That has been very good to us in many regards.
Thank you. Melissa Martinez.
Hello. Hi. So I have a couple
of questions. My questions about accessibility,
such as how have the needs have changed for youth and
elders programming during the Pandemic and also
for our disability communities?
And how do staff and support needed to support these equitable access to
these programs? And also mentioned
in slide 27 in the budget, I noticed that there was
an investment of 14 million and improved 18 neighborhoods,
parks, and community centers. What would the impacts be if budgets
were to be doubled, say, like 28 million to help with these accessibility?
I think the Mayor's 50 50 initiative is right on target
with exactly what you're doing, especially in complete communities. That's been our
emphasis. Community is only as good as the parks
around it, and giving young people the opportunity to
participate with funding of nice parks is
one of the initiatives that we're front and center with what we're trying to
do. Council Member David Robinson. Thank you. I just wanted to mention to Ms.
Martinez that our Director of the Mayor's Office for Persons with Disabilities,
Gabe Cassidas, recently presented to the TTI
committee that we chair. And that presentation did talk about accessibility
generally, but also within the context
of parks access. So you may find that posted on the city
website under the TTI committee heading,
and I think you might find that helpful considering your question.
Okay. I know Director Allen. We made a lot of adjustments during
the Pandemic. We took the basketball goals down. We did
a lot of things. If I made the statement that we're pretty
close to where we were pre Pandemic, is that accurate?
Yes. Okay. So I think you'll see more and
more of that where, especially when the summer rolls through, hopefully we can get the
lifeguards out. It's going to be a hot summer.
It's going to be a dry summer. It was funny
because many of us went to a Houston prayer breakfast this morning.
I know many of our officers did as well. And Mr.
Herzog from one of the TV stations was talking about the drought and the conditions
and how he hates it. And I was the only one that actually love a
drought because love in a drought means we
have no storms coming yet and we need to be prepared
because the area that I live in was pretty devastated, as is
council member Jackson's. But Abby came and shaking her head, no, but I
love droughts. Difference of opinion. Thank you. We will now transition.